we really as engineers need to take
responsibility to work on the things
that will make the world a better place
taking responsibility having a research
strategy instead of just going wherever
your curiosity takes you AI and
optimization have very different
strengths than humans do humans are
really good at actually figuring out
what the ins are what the value
judgments are in general how it should
trade-off between different things like
various forms of efficiency and various
forms of fairness but he must think of
them in the context of special cases and
humans are very bad as actually sifting
through all of the possible special
cases of which there are more than the
number of atoms in the universe we
developed this new framework which we
call future match where we take as input
the humans value judgments and then
using AI based simulation and past data
we can actually optimize the policy
parameters as to how do you best achieve
those goals so we're separating the
means and the ends the humans are
talking about ends and the AI is
figuring out the means and I think that
this is a very important separation for
the future in many different areas of AI
you